[Music]
an appeal from the trump campaign that
challenged nevada's election process
is dismissed by the nevada supreme court
this after the campaign and clark county
reached an agreement over the issue
meantime vote counting almost complete
in southern nevada county officials
saying 1200 ballots were processed
yesterday
and today was the very last day mail-in
ballots were accepted
but with some local races so close could
there be a recount
orco mana spoke to an expert to get the
answer
the two local races we're focusing on
are the clark county commission district
c
race and the state senate district six
race now both of those contests
are extremely tight one historian we
spoke to says
recounts are possible but they might not
be effective
history in nevada of having some really
close races and the 2020 election is no
exception the latest numbers for the
clark county commission district c
race has democrat ross miller only about
600 votes ahead of republican stavros
anthony and in the battle over nevada
state senate district six democratic
incumbent nicole canazzaro only leads
republican april becker by roughly 800
votes
it's not that big a shocker perhaps unlv
history professor michael green
tells me a tight contest often leads to
a recount but it can be a game of chance
for the challenger
does the losing candidate want to take
the risk when one
that candidate is on the hook if the
result doesn't change
and two recounts usually find
votes for the winning candidate green
points to the 1998 u.s senate race
between harry reid and john ensign
reed was winning statewide by about 401
votes
it came out to 428 with the recount i
have some inquiries about exactly how
the process works clark county registrar
of voters joe gloria says his office is
prepared to do recounts but the earliest
that could happen is next week
after the canvas is complete they need
to make that request within three days
and then at the same time pay the fee
for us to recount those ballots green
says that could be costly
it can be substantial to do a recount i
reached out to miller
anthony cannazzaro and becker about a
potential recount in their races
but they did not get back to me in
regards to the presidential race
green says biden has a wide enough lead
that he does not expect president trump
to ask for a recount here in nevada
orco mana 8 news now orco thank you